welcome back to glamour unfiltered host
by me josh smith and in a very special
edition of glamour unfiltered we are
going to meet
some of the nhs frontline workers who
kept this country going
during the global pandemic
so what's your experience been like of
working in nhs
during the last year and how's that
changed how's that pivoted
i think at the start of it um everybody
was just
you know rabbit and headlights how are
we going to get through
this we're going to run at a bed
capacity it's just going to be traumatic
for everybody you know personally
professionally
you know just at all sorts of levels and
i think to begin with um it was that
just that adrenaline
got us through and the whole thing about
we are the nhs we're gonna we're gonna
rise to this and
we're gonna make things happen um and
then fortunately we didn't run out of
beds and services got
um stepped down and just the most
amazing you know
you think something's so negative and
and so stressful
and we we had such a wonderful
experience here with staff that had
um previously been working maybe in
sexual health services and children's
services
and just that can do attitude we'll get
through it together
we found ourselves with um staff
sickness
and everyone going off for kind of all
at once it was a matter of everyone just
covering each other
working weekends working on each ward
just helping each other out and
trying to do okay i'm a therapist but if
the nurses needed help if the healthcare
assistants needed help just trying to
pitch in wherever you can
people were dying and people were
suffering from it and even the people
that
were coming through onto the other side
were still experiencing
what we now know is long covered like
the
the effects of on their breathing on
their walking and their day-to-day were
still so impacted
we've had a lot of patients who've had
lots of long
itu stays um acute stage where they've
been on
um in comas basically with covid
and when they've awoken they're really
out of breath they're not able to stand
now able to walk because it's completely
taken them off their feet completely
knocked them for six they've had
been there for months and so they come
to us until they're ready to go home so
that we can get them back on their feet
doing the things that they used to do
before
you saw all extremes you know you saw
you saw the the very ill patients the
patients without their family without
their friends
you know without um you know things
happening in the real world
um and and then really not having you
know
a connection with that and with
patients not really understanding what
this virus was
patients that were cognitively impaired
and to them it just was very strange
that
you know suddenly we were all running
around and fill ppe
gear and and just you know the
importance that you put
on communication um for for patients
with cognitive impairment
um and then you know the non-verbals the
eye contact the the lip reading
whatever it might be and and it took us
such a long time
to to really understand how to
communicate better
and wearing a mask you took a break to
go traveling and then
obviously covered 19 here and then you
decided to put yourself
onto the front line literally the front
line going to people's homes
why did you decide to do that
what was the calling that made you
decide that you wanted to go do it
i think if you're a nurse
it's really hard to then not not be a
nurse you get itchy feet
and when the opportunity arose i was
just like yeah let's go
i'm not sure if the
me before i took my career break could
have
handled this um but i've been and i
think if you'd asked me then
about you you'd be working on the front
line in a pandemic
i'd have probably been like oh no i
wouldn't go near that
but um yeah i definitely feel
that i've changed um as a person and as
a nurse
and i'm a lot more sure of myself and
what i'm capable of
how's the nhs looked after your guys
mental health during this
would you say how's how you leaned into
each other and how has
have you guys felt supported during this
time the pressure comes and it gets more
intense
more like this is actually here to stay
what are we going to do how are we going
to cope with this
and then that starts then impacting on
everything else so when you're in it
and everything's really exciting and
you're just like reacting because that's
what we do best
and then actually you think i can't do
this for
like for the foreseeable future there's
got to be something that we're going to
be able to change we've got to do
something different and what's that
going to be
none of us know so we just had to like
just take it as it came really
i've always been a very anxious person
which
is one of the reasons why i struggled
with going back to nursing
so much but i do it is about the team
that i'm in
and the support that i've received from
them um
that have really kept me going through
this and having
um really experienced and
um probably can we were saying this but
older nurses
they're not they're just older than me
i'm the youngest one
who have just taken me under their wing
really and
it's been and it's been tricky
obviously the the pandemic has had
an effect on so many people in so many
different ways
and in some ways it's been really
difficult
seeing a lot of what's been going on and
how
bad kovid is but in other ways we've
felt really lucky because
at least we've been able to keep working
and we've been able to do something
about what's happening
um so i think it's just about
for me trying to just look on the
positive side of things
um and speak to people when you're not
when you're
not dealing with things or you need help
dealing with something
do you think it's taught you more about
your own personal
power in a way in that you're actually
like it surprised you
how resilient you've been through this
whole thing yeah i think i feel a lot
more
resilient and feel a lot more tough and
that
when things were altering daily and we
were having to alter the way
we work daily and help them to move
clinics and
speak to patients and reassure patients
so yeah i feel a lot more
resilient that i can cope people empower
themselves i think we've got
in us a lot more than we realize and
you get thrown in this situation that
we've all said or imagine if
this time last year somebody said this
was going to happen but we're all a lot
more resilient than we give ourselves
credit for
how did it affect your kind of your
family life because i guess if you're
going out and you're having to work on
the front line and then
you have to consider and you're worried
about what's happening to your family
but also your patients and everything
else
i have a 10 year old daughter and she
has cerebral palsy
so she is at risk but not at risk
compared to other children with the same
disease so i think
for me it was the anxiety around
juggling
i had to look after my team and my
patients and do my job
but i suddenly had my daughter at home
who's 10 years old
and not needy but you know she was
anxious as well
you know suddenly i can't see my friends
and she hates culvert by the way
she could it's like stopped her having
her birthday party which she had every
year
so it it probably had more an impact i
would say on my family life because
i managed to keep work going yeah
settled like you do
but but in terms of the home front i
think you know juggling child care
initially
every time there was a potential
heartbreak the kids had to stay at home
and you had to stay with them
but still work virtually i think that
was a challenge
um and still a challenge now because the
schools are still closing
or threatening to close so it would be
good to see the other side of this
and it's hard because i couldn't see my
you know family for months and months so
i guess
that was really really tough i lived
with my boyfriend so that helped
um kind of coming home and i ended up
switching off the news
um because it's just kind of when you're
working and then you come home and see
it more that can bog you down
so i think like everyone did started
doing the
zoom quizzes and everything there's a
colleague that i worked with um
last year on another project that i did
doing for an inpatient unit in kingswood
center
and she kind of always brings me back
down to earth because i'm saying oh yeah
and she's like oh gosh you're getting
home late and i'm like oh it's mental
like there's so much going on you just
got to do everything all of the time
just make sure you just keep your head
above water and she says to me
don't forget why you're doing it because
the job will still be there but your
kids won't but you know what i mean like
they this is ridiculous but don't worry
i don't even know why i'm getting so
excited so silly
just take a take a moment you sit down
you talk to
you guys and you're so not used to
talking about yourselves or
talking about the amazing work you do
yeah
and i think you guys need to give
yourselves more credit for the
incredible work you're doing day in day
out
is there someone you can remember giving
you an amazing piece of advice
and you were like wow that's really
amazing or someone who's really been
kind of like
your hero in your career almost my rapid
response team
are incredible i've got some really
amazing women
um huna and christine they're all
just incredible and they've all got
different qualities
that make them really good nurses and
really good professionals
um and i just feel really lucky to be a
part of a team
they'll really inspire me has it maybe
taught you about the power of
sisterhood and how incredible that can
be when you lean into it as well
i think just women
uplifting women is
we don't give it enough credit and i
think we like to sometimes put women
against each other
and that's just not the case so it's not
the experience my experience anyway um
especially
in this situation um
they've all been like
just really supportive um with the best
intentions
despite all the horrible things that
happened during that time what did it
kind of show you about
the power of human resilience and kind
of like humanity
the support from everyone like your
local communities i mean we were getting
things delivered to us and people
showing their support and
obviously the thursday claps were really
nice but also like you know i was
getting messages from my friends and my
family my loved ones like saying
just checking in seeing how i was and
that was really nice too
and more professionally i guess
those people who did have covered who
did come through it like being able to
work with them
and seeing them you know getting people
from who
were like bed bound and not able to move
or even stand up without like
rasping for breath having them leaving
the ward a few weeks later like walking
was just like that kind of kept me going
because mean meant i was making
a difference a lot of it for me is just
having the support of colleagues like
the clap thing they they put out i don't
know whose idea that was but
they really need frankie because that
really it made us
feel like everyone cared like because
usually
obviously everyone appreciates the nhs
but not you don't really unders you
can't take it for granted don't you like
anything else
and but actually that was quite nice
that kind of helped us through
everyone looked forward to that point of
the week where everyone was
the whole nation was thanking you for
doing your job because even
when we was going out and my husband was
like oh yeah we're all clapping for you
and i said well you're not because i'm
not on the front line
i'm behind the scenes do you see
yourself as a
hero in a way oh no i i don't i know
there's this thing about
the hand clapping i mean when i look at
my other colleagues that
maybe work on the wards that have
directly managed culvert patients for
longer periods of time
i probably see them as more of an arrow
because i would probably be very scared
we did help on the wards up here
and i did find that quite um anxious at
the time because i've not worked on a
ward for about
18 years suddenly to go into the ward
setting to help during covert was very
nerve-racking
so i wouldn't see myself as a hero but i
think i would see
the pa you know the staff that are on
the wards that are looking after
patients that are positive
because i think the thought of the risk
is even more stronger because
yes you've got ppe but you are you know
we all make mistakes we're all human
and that's where the risk of the the
infection comes in
so i would see them as more heroes and i
would see
myself as supporting the networks if you
can give any advice to anyone who's
watching this
who maybe thinks oh we're coming to the
end the vaccine is coming what would you
want to say about
the impact of what this year's had and
why we need to keep going
i've been able to see firsthand what
families are going through
and even though we think i'll be coming
out the other side there are
still people out there losing their
loved ones or
having to deal with this somewhere in a
house somewhere
that it's still it's still very very
real and i think
it's just to you know keep following the
rules keep being mindful what
you know what's still out there until
you know it's safe to say that we're out
on the other side
if someone's going to come and say to
you and be like i want to join the nhs
what advice would you give them would
you say just go for it do it as
stressful as this job is i love my job
and it's going to sound very cliche
but you know when they say to you if you
love what you do you never have to work
a day in your life
like i you majority of the time i'm
balancing out ready for the morning i am
so happy to come into work
i really do love my job i think it's an
amazing career
um no matter how
much i've thought and i have thought
before have i made the right decision
um because it can be tough um
i don't want to romanticize the whole
thing that
it's one of the best careers that you
can ever do but there are days when
you're like this
is really hard i don't know if i can
keep doing it but um
when i wasn't doing it it was all i was
thinking about
and it's just so fulfilling
and it just gives you so much purpose oh
it's an amazing profession
why would i still be in there just this
many decades into my career
it is an amazing amazing profession